anything you want to say to sneaker
i didn't really watch it i like i
stopped i stopped watching
because i couldn't watch
like
you know you know you know me when
people don't let people talk you know
you don't mean right
so and even like i hate myself when i
find myself in that position when i
don't let people talk and i get too much
in my emotion and all that [ __ ]
that still happens what happens
sometimes
but less less a lot less because i hate
it so much and the minute i see it
like i said and
on top of that when the person
it's so it's one thing to cut someone
off when when i find doing my when i
find myself doing that is when you know
the conversation is heated yeah
but when a [ __ ] is not even
heated
like the other person's heated the like
the person talking is not even heated
yeah like okay so hey man right like yo
yo you're just doing that [ __ ] on your
own
because sometimes the other person
that's talking is heated and the way
he's going to be talking to you is going
to be very
directed to you like it's going to be
you know he's not going to be talking to
you he's going to be talking at you yeah
right there's a difference and then it's
it's it shifts the energy of the
conversation when you're not even
talking and it triggers you to do that
right i understand that now it's fine
when the person is not even doing that
and you're just it's really you being
your feelings and your emotions and i
understand that i understand that
where it's from
and i understand how it is like i'm not
dogging him for that uh
it's so emotional i get that because
i was that person you understand what
i'm saying so i get where he's from and
the anger is from and everything and
stuff
but not i i just i can't watch that i
can't i just can't i can't watch it
you i'll be i'll be talking that's why
people were like yo why don't you spend
time like talking to young folks
i like sneakers i know him personally so
for me it's like you know make time for
somebody i know
but like if you're 20 in your opinion
you run up on me i'm not gonna lie i
might laugh in your face kind of like
that kid who's talking about like
spiritual warfare and talking about how
like we're under cosmic control i
laughed in his face i'm not gonna lie
because that [ __ ] was funny to me yeah
but like the human brain can only
conceptualize so much things because we
are only humans i'm telling you like
everything is literally vibration and we
we can't understand that as humans you
know um we derive really from aliens you
know like aliens and ufos like i'm
telling you bro like from the bottom of
my heart bro like that [ __ ] is so real
you know
bro
how old are you i'm 18.
from when you were 10 to when you were
18 do you feel like you understand the
world a bit better from 10 to 18. yeah
but the word is literally still the same
though in the sense you know i just
i just asked you i i just yeah
yeah right is it not possible
that your understanding is coming from
experience and learning isn't it
possible that yeah like that isn't it
i'm just gonna finish is it possible
that the things that we don't understand
is not due to some necessarily cosmic
force but our inability to understand
all the variables involved in the things
around us yes i agree with that as well
you know but the cosmic force is what
controls everything like i promise you
like bro you're under you're under
spiritual control like literally at all
times of the day you know like god
doesn't give you anything too late or
like too early when i say god i'm not
talking about like a christian god or
anything i'm talking about the whole
universe you know um like it's always
controlling you and always like helping
you at all times you know and like like
when i say aliens and stuff like that
doesn't mean like oh let like these
aliens want to take over the world they
literally are here to help you know
humankind you know today society is so
[ __ ] terrible you you make videos
about it you know like bro like why are
people so like like unhappy and
everything it's because of social media
you know like they put these things in
our lives you know to control us you
know make us unhappy you know and like
that [ __ ] is like astrology is not like
prejudice towards you know like saying
like this will determine your
personality and stuff like some people
over blow it you know like you know
those girls who like just talk about you
know childhood juice
to to say that oh you know this is my
personality like no you know like you
have to you actually have an actual
personality you know behind you know
what is really like
a you know different from a child
bro you know but like bro life is
interesting bro i'm like
what's so [ __ ] funny bro
like
i mean [ __ ] don't laugh you know but
you know it's fine
i'm sorry i can't i'm crying
you know and you know
humanity just has to change you know you
oh no like humanity just has to change
you know
but you know what it is about young
folks shout outs to y'all
um
i don't know maybe i i didn't feel like
i was like this when i was young because
i you know i was used to shutting my
mouth but
i don't mind if [ __ ] don't know
[ __ ] but when they uh aggressively
ignorant that's always funny to me all
right actually i got time you know what
i mean yeah cause i said that before
yeah but i said that before right
when you don't know that you don't know
you don't know that you don't know yeah
right sounds super stupid at first but
if you think about it you know you on
your perspective that person is going to
be aggressively ignorant they don't know
that they don't know
they just right think that they know
because they don't know that they don't
know yeah the more that you know the
more that you know that you don't know
well there's something funny like at 15
you think you see life one way then you
get to like 24 25 then you like learn
about a bunch of stuff then you like oh
now i see the world you get like 30 32
you're like oh [ __ ] i really don't know
nothing
the only thing you realize with age is
how little you know
and how open you're gonna have to be
about a lot of stuff
that's it i just know it's not that i'm
much more intel none of that
i just know my limits which means i get
to be more effective that's when someone
rolls up on me say what do you think
about the monkey box
and i'm comfortable saying it oh i have
no problem telling you i don't know
sometimes [ __ ] mean
conversation you mean using words i'm
like i know what that means tell me what
that means i do not care
about not knowing something i'll ask you
and if i don't want to be informed i'll
say let me stay ignorant but i know i am
that's the only difference that that and
it's so comforting oh my god do you know
how great it is to know that i don't
know something about something and i
don't want to learn you know somebody
like abba what about canadian uh shut
the [ __ ] up
no
i don't care about the queen and why
she's here and why her [ __ ] don't stink
don't give a [ __ ]
don't care
sometimes people try to shh
let me stay in here
there's knowledge i don't want to put in
this brain
but you don't want to learn that's
ignorant i know [ __ ] i'm trying to tell
you i know
i know what i'm angry about
and i embrace it
and on the other hand
sometimes you do know
and you don't give a [ __ ] but you should
care that's like brother you can't care
about everything you can carry yeah you
can't
i was lost down people possible try to
zone in on something and put your time
and get you trying to be a jack of all
trades when it comes to everything in
the world means you know nothing okay
just you feel good thinking you know a
lot so for me i pick my battles i'm good
i'm good yeah so i saw the first video
about you once nico i started watching
it you know when it became too much i
turned i shut that [ __ ] off i was like
ugh
two dudes that know each other having a
conversation great y'all do you yeah all
right and then i rolled up and i thought
it was the second video and that [ __ ]
was like 36 minutes and i was like oh
hell no oh no this one is much more
civil i'm not i'm not i'm already i'm no
no no i'm not watching it because i know
it's not it's it's [ __ ]
yeah i know you by now but you know
what's funny oh you know people said i
have oh my god you got so much patience
it's not even that i got so much
patience i'm just i don't care
like i'm sitting in front of somebody
sometimes they leave me yelling and
screaming go ahead
i'm a robber do you
i'll wait till you done i don't care
that's why mid conversation someone
wasting my time i'll just leave the
conversation i don't care
just
you don't have to listen to me
i'll be trying you don't have to listen
to anything i [ __ ] abba you guys
change i'm done with you bye
get to a point where you're not so
invested in any outcome i don't go into
the conversation like i'm going to
change your mind and oh i'm going to
talk and if you want to listen listen if
you don't that's okay too but i'm
certainly not going to sit here
and emotionally invest myself into
anything where someone's just like
losing their [ __ ] or what i'm not gonna
i ain't got the energy you know
someone's like yo why don't you why'd
you go more open-minded you know
sometimes i have like young women trying
to dm me like 19 20.
you think i've got the emotional
openness to be able to listen to you
yeah what the worst part is like you
need you got so much turbulence and [ __ ]
to figure out that's why i always laugh
when all these red people do is talking
about like i want an 18 19 year old
because she ain't got no biases like but
you can tolerate the yipping yapping
i look i know there's a lot of young
people who are decent people that's
fantastic but you gotta
hey man let me tell you i go to bed at
night and i sleep good and i ain't
training that for nothing if you take
anywhere from this conversation your
peace of mind matters
invest in that
invest in that
i had too many sleepless nights over
[ __ ] i should have never been inside of
dead ass i've had too many sleepless
nights over [ __ ] i should have never
been inside of because i was thinking
with my dick
your [ __ ] dumb
well [ __ ] done were your [ __ ] done
my [ __ ] done yeah you were sticking with
your dick yeah yeah yeah
she ain't too pretty in the face but
she's super thick
you was thinking with your dick hey man
i know if there's some lyrics i've never
seen it don't okay i don't know
i was like yo this [ __ ] says my dick is
done one more time i'm about to fight
this [ __ ]